for that you need a more complex storage
system like web sequel or indexdb web
sequel provides a sequel Lite based
database directly in the browser you can
use sequel queries to access data and
define relationships and you can have
structured data in your value storage as
well now this is significantly more
complex than the simple and limited key
value storage in local store however
there's two main problems with it the
first problem is although this API is
available in Chrome Safari and opera and
iOS Safari in the Android browser even
it's not available on ie or Firefox the
second problem is clear from the
specification which is no longer being
maintained in short web sequel is a dead
end it's out there in Chrome the Android
browser Safari and iOS Safari and opera
but it's not available in ie or Firefox
and it's likely that it never will be